bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france24 notre invité aujourd'hui et
jean ping il est ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères du gabon il a aussi
été président de la commission de
l'union africaine
il a été candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2016 scrutin contesté
émaillées de violences qu'il affirme
encore aujourd'hui avoir gagné contre
ali bongo après des années il a décidé
de briser le silence sur les réseaux
sociaux est aujourd'hui sur france 24
depuis libreville la capitale gabonaise
merci à vous d'être avec nous monsieur
ping et moi qui alors dans un discours
en date du 19 février vous appelez je
cite les institutions a déclaré la
vacance du pouvoir en raison de la santé
d'ali bongo on rappelle à nos
téléspectateurs qu'ali bongo a été
victime d'un accident vasculaire
cérébral un avc le 24 octobre 2018
pourquoi est ce que vous appelez
maintenant à la vacance du pouvoir
j'écoutais chapelle à la vacance du
pouvoir parce que
le pouvoir est bas qu'à vous savez
ali bongo a usurpé les élections il a
utilisé la violence ou s'imposer et
maintenant il n'est plus visible son
état de santé et sur tous les réseaux
sur dans le monde entier au revoir à
l'epo en train de tituber
rattrapé de justesse par nathan pour ne
pas tomber on le voit à bruxelles la
même manière et il est devenu un zombie
malade
et donc
vous considérez qu'il n'est plus en
capacité d'exercer la présidence du
pouvoir c'est bien ce que vous nous
dites
et sur cc c'est visible ça saute aux
yeux dans leurs rangs tous les
téléspectateurs du monde entier vous
regarde la tv operandi réaliser vous
même vous l'année derrière
il a une super voix il ne peut même pas
exister
alors quand vous dites que vous demandez
aux institutions de déclaré la vacance
du pouvoir à qui précisément faites vous
appel et en d'autres mots qu'est ce que
vous espérez qui va se passer suite à
votre appel
je demande la vacance du pouvoir parce
que c'est là s'impose acquis du doigt
notamment à la course aux nez et aux
autres institutions de la république qui
seront connus
à ce que ali n'est plus en mesure
d'exercer ce pouvoir c'est ghislain
alors l'avait sermon il ya plus de trois
ans pourquoi est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
voulez déclaré la vacance du pouvoir
pourquoi est-ce que tout d'un coup
maintenant est ce que ce n'est pas pour
le dire autrement une façon d'appeler à
un soulèvement peut être populaire
contre ali bongo
j'ai toujours évité agassi ligne comme
vous le savez j'ai toujours proclamé la
nécessité d'une transition pacifique
afin d'éviter la violence et la gacilly
mais
pendant ce temps aux jouets 2
et donc 6 vous n'êtes plus 2 qu'est ce
que vous demandez aux gabonais est ce
que vous leur demander de descendre dans
la rue de manifester pacifiquement ou
moins pacifiquement concrètement qu'est
ce que vous leur dites aujourd'hui
et continue nous disons simplement que
la vacance du pouvoir s'impose
puis que d'une manière ou d'une autre
même si les gabonais sont des gens très
passe équipe
même si les cas promet sont des gens qui
ont toujours évité
les violences il y a le temps poteau
et viendra le temps c'est sera
supportable je pense que c'est un éclat
tiquement à nos portes
et donc à quoi appeler vous précisément
est ce que vous demandez aux gens de
descendre dans la rue de manifester on a
vu ça dans d'autres pays est ce un appel
à l'insurrection
on en a besoin de comprendre ce que vous
voulez monsieur kim
d je pense que je vais être suffisamment
clair
un lbo n'existe plus
halim aux
super pouvoirs qu'il ne peut même plus
exercer on le voit ça saute aux yeux
c'est de venir et zombies qui va ici et
là et qui limite ulises tout le cas tous
les africains sont en train de dire que
le caron et de génie un pays
qui fait on reste donc aux points chacun
nos responsabilités alors vous dites
aussi dans votre discours je cite que
ali bongo sert de marionnettes à de
nouveaux usurpateur qui livre le pays
aux enchères qui sont ces nouveaux
usurpateurs monsieur ping
était ali bongo est entouré terroristes
de terroristes terroristes mais il est
trop rist il est en tous les terroristes
il est entouré de gens qui
chacun le plus malin cherche à prendre
le pouvoir et
et tout ces gens gesticule et il connaît
forcément réaction au sénat qui visez
vous monsieur ping quand vous dites il
ya des gens qui sont des terreaux vous
avez quelques noms en tête on imagine
vous dites pas ça comme ça à la légère
ce n'est pas tout à fait votre style
il y à des terroristes au gabon c'est
une liste non seulement pour donner les
mêmes exemples concrets sont venus
bombardé au cij comme vous le savez sont
venus bombardé le parti général et celui
qui a gagné les élections bombardé
nuitamment ils ont tué une dizaine de
personnes et puis sur les dents les
dégâts à dire dans la grande banlieue
parisienne où ils ont massacré avec
quelques blessés n'est
comprenez que c'est évident et il y a
donc parmi ceux qui l'entourent parmi
les va-t-en-guerre les gens qui pensent
que il faut brûler le gabon il faut
mettre le capot à feu et à sang si
ils boivent belle il faut que tout le
monde paie la politique de
monsieur ping vous parlez quand même
deux choses très graves vous parler de
terrorisme et vous ne voulez pas les
nommer qui sont ils
si telerman
tu viens l'oublier au gabon il y a des
gens qui sont venus au siège
il wenger les élections à mon siège au
quartier général mon mari me tamaro
siège envahi et massacré une bise est
élevé
ces gens sont
manipulés par les soldats
est-ce que c'est complet à écouter oui
mais vous ne voulez pas dire qui
précisément mais c'est pas grave la
présidence a réagi à ce discours en
disant qu'en fait c'est le discours d'un
leader en perte de vitesse est vrai que
depuis 2016 pas mal de soutiens vous ont
quitté est ce que en effet vous ne
voulez pas vous rappeler aux bons
souvenirs des gens parce qu'on est en
train de vous oublier et finalement que
votre avenir est peut-être en jeu
je ne le pense pas du tout je suis en
train
fixé la ligne à suivre le tracé la ligne
azur
mêmes partisans sont là je les vois tous
les fronts il suffit de claquer les
doigts pour que il avance dans une
direction ou dans une simplement je vous
ai dit je ne souhaite pas
que le gabon quand un gosse il
tu ne le souhaite pas donc je fais tout
haut que la passation de quoi se fasse
d'une manière
comme agrège pacifique mais ce que vous
dites quand même pour qu'on comprenne la
prochaine élection est fixé l'an
prochain en 2023 là en voulant que la
vacance du pouvoir soient déclarés vous
affirmer qu'il ne faut pas attendre la
prochaine élection pour qu'ils aient une
transition pacifique du pouvoir c'est
bien ça oui
parce que il n'y aura pas d'élections
avant nos accédants poids de toute façon
avant 2023
d'une manière ou d'une autre donc ça
veut dire je reprends quand même parce
que c'est important pour les gens qui
nous écoutent surtout au gabon que vous
pensez que ali bongo sera chassé du
pouvoir avant la prochaine élection fixé
en 2023
c'est le c'est tout à fait ça il doit
dégager à lisbourg ne peut plus
s'occuper mais sa santé personnelle
comme vous le voyez tous plus s'occuper
de sa santé personnelle
vous niez oui mais vous n'attendez quand
même pas ce qu'il vous obéissent enfin
si s'il ne le fait pas est ce que vous
êtes prêts à attendre finalement 2023 où
vous dites non je ne vais pas attendre
et celle de la main
nous le dégagement d'une
donc d'une manière ou d'une autre ça
peut être d'une manière pacifique
ou d'une manière violente ou brutale
c'est la seule conclusion qu'on peut
tirer non monsieur ping je crois
donc vous vous êtes prêts à chasser ali
bongo du pouvoir y compris par les armes
écoutez
ce n'est pas moi qui décide
de l'utilisation des âmes je voudrais
vous rappeler celle m
que les nations unies
l'onu
a fixé un principe qu'on appelle la
responsabilité de protéger
ça veut dire que si
quand ivan un dictateur ou un autre
massacre sa propre population il est du
devoir de la communauté internationale
de s'interposer pour diriger les
habitants du massacre
dernière question est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que la communauté
internationale justement à oublier le
gabon depuis cette élection de 2016 et
est ce que vous le regrettez
oui je ne sais pas s'il a oublié mais je
le plaît parce que c'est tellement
aujourd'hui
vous parler du lequel
on parle l'ukraine et en parlant du
lucre et on dit qu'il faut sauver la
démocratie et sauver la souveraineté de
l'ukraine pour disons aventures du gamin
il n'y a pas de liberté
jean ping je vous remercie beaucoup
d'avoir répondu aux questions de france
24 depuis libreville et merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cet entretien sur nos
antennes restez-y pour plus
d'informations
[Musique]